if you're building a web or mobile app
in 2022 there's literally a million
different ways to get the job done by
combining different front-end and
back-end libraries along with apis
tooling and infrastructure to form a
complete tech stack in today's video i
want to give you a guided tour of my
tech stack which i plan on using through
2025 assuming the world hasn't been
destroyed by that point not only will i
explain my thought process when making
these decisions but we'll also look at a
ton of alternatives that you may want to
consider for yourself because you
definitely shouldn't just copy some
random guy on youtube before we get into
it as many of you know i recently had a
baby i haven't been uploading quite as
many videos but it's given me time to
work on a complete rebuild of fireship
io and in the process i've analyzed all
kinds of different technologies that i
might want to use for that project now i
don't really need to rebuild fireship
but i do it every couple years just
because i enjoy the process most of the
coding i'll do with my bare hands but
the project will be open source and i
will likely collaborate with a couple of
other engineers to round out the project
it's a small team effort which is an
important consideration when choosing
your tech stack because many
technologies are more well-suited for
large teams software engineers love to
flex that tech stack gotta be bustin or
drippin in other words ridiculously
over-engineered the reality is that i
could build fireship as a wordpress blog
add a membership plugin and scale it up
to millions of users if i want to make
money that would be the smart thing to
do but i want to build something a
little more special than just a
wordpress blog in the next version of
the site courses will have progress
tracking that will also include
challenges like quizzes and interactive
demos powered by stack blitz in my
experience the majority of modern web
development happens on the front end
that being said one of the most
important decisions to make is your
front-end ui library and for that i have
chosen svelt i've built something with
pretty much every ui library on the
market they all have their pros and cons
but svelte is the one that feels most
productive to me and coincidentally just
yesterday it debuted at the top of the
most loved web frameworks on the stack
overflow 2022 survey i think developers
love it for how natural it makes
reactive data feel when a mutable
variable changes the ui reacts you don't
have to jump through any weird hoops to
make things reactive now the other thing
i really like about spelt is the way you
share data across components which is
done with stores a store is like a
subject in rxjs that can be observed
anywhere in the application by simply
putting a dollar sign in front of it
this pattern is actually very similar to
the way things are done in angular but
svelte does it with a lot less
boilerplate the current version of
fireship is actually built with angular
and in my opinion angular is awesome and
the most underappreciated framework out
there it's extremely popular in
enterprise for a good reason but in 2022
react is definitely still the most
popular ui library and it has a huge
ecosystem of supporting libraries i
think that's the most compelling
argument to use it when it comes down to
the ui library itself there are cleaner
options out there like solid js that
would also provide better performance i
also seriously considered vue which is
not only a great framework but also has
a large number of supporting libraries
as well but the more important decision
is which meta framework do you want to
use react has next view as next angular
has universal and svelt has kit most
applications out there need some form of
server-side rendering to make their
sites visible to search engines and bots
spelt kit is the official ssr solution
that's being worked on by rich harris
but as of today it's still in beta using
a framework that's not at a stable
release is kind of risky you could pour
a ton of work into an app then the
framework developers decide to pull a
feature on the final release that
torpedoes your entire business not very
likely so that's a risk i'm willing to
take now there are other ways to server
render spelt another good option is
astro it has a lot of awesome features
for content driven sites but the reason
i prefer spelt kit for this project is
because it does client-side routing
after the initial page load which
becomes important on more interactive
sites especially when user
authentication is involved but my plan
is to use astro for my personal
portfolio if i ever get around to
rebuilding it now the other framework
that i would say is my second choice is
next js next is already a great
framework but it has a bunch of cool
stuff coming as well like nested routing
and stuff like that i also recently made
a video on next yet another awesome
framework that i hope to make a full
course on in the future it's also worth
mentioning that there's a new framework
called quick that has an entirely
different take on rendering with
resumable or replayable applications but
even that's a little too bleeding edge
for me now when it comes to server
rendering you don't need to use a meta
framework that's tied to some javascript
library instead you can use a full stack
framework like ruby on rails laravel
django or whatever to render all of your
content on the server these frameworks
have advantages for certain types of
applications but in my case full-blown
server-side rendering is not really
necessary because the content on the
actual site doesn't change all that
often it's far more simple to pre-render
the entire site upload it to a storage
bucket and then cache it on a cdn around
the world when you have a dedicated
server you then need to think about how
to scale it with either serverless
functions or if you want a really
complicated tech stack something like
kubernetes the next thing i want to talk
about is typescript if you're building a
big complicated project you should use
it in the end a more complicated
question you'll have to ask is how am i
going to manage my css when i work on a
solo project i spend more time [ __ ]
around with the css than i do writing
javascript it's depressing man i've only
got so much time left to hold fortran 3.
life goes by much faster than we think
yet here i am wasting hours of this
precious time trying to figure out why
this navbar won't be sticky that being
said a tool that makes css much easier
is tailwind most importantly it makes
prototyping and the implementation of
your designs go much faster i like to
have a lot of control over my designs
because for me it's a creative process
tailwind won't magically make your
website look good but it does provide
enough of a framework to get things done
way quicker the current version of
fireship is 100 custom with sas with
tailwind i feel like i have the same
amount of control but things just get
done much more rapidly and another huge
benefit is that it will automatically
purge styles to keep the css bundle as
small as possible that's important
because the initial page load speed for
my site is critical if you like the
utility class approach another option to
check out is windy css or if you don't
care about having that much control you
can use something like bootstrap in
addition to many other css frameworks
out there and you've also got tons of
framework-specific ui libraries to
analyze as well and if you're using
tailwind you should definitely check out
daisy ui but i'm just doing everything
from scratch myself because i'm an idiot
that's enough for the front end now i
want to talk about the back end as you
know i'm a big fan of firebase and it's
been the foundation of this channel from
day one but as i've grown older and
wiser i've come to realize something
about firebase this may be shocking to
some of you but firebase is still
awesome and i plan on using it until the
day i die or at least until google
decides to kill it whichever comes first
firebase will do 90 of what most apps
need on the back end the main drawback
is that you're tightly locked into
google cloud platform and you may run
into edge cases that it just doesn't
support like advanced authentication
features or complex database queries and
that can be a deal breaker for certain
types of apps what you could do is
architect your entire backend from
scratch by picking and choosing
different services in the cloud but then
the complexity of your code base is
going to explode luckily in 2022 there
are quite a few alternatives to firebase
you've got big ones like aws amplify and
mongodb realm and then smaller startups
like enho superbase and app right i
recently compared all of them and each
one has its own set of unique trade-offs
expect a full video on that soon the
most important thing is the database
firebase uses firestore which is a
document database similar to mongodb
which can get the job done for most apps
but does have some limitations that can
be kind of annoying at times a
traditional sql database is probably the
safest bet for most people but they're
generally harder to work with although
there are some services out there like
planet scale and cockroachdb that have
made things a lot easier in recent years
especially when used with an orm like
prisma in addition you might consider
other nosql databases like redis and
cassandra which can actually be used as
a primary app database now in addition
to the back end there are a lot of other
smaller tools in the stack when it comes
to testing i find that i need to keep
things very simple otherwise i'm not
going to test anything at all and my
preferred way to do that is with cyprus
which is basically an all-in-one package
that can do everything from end-to-end
tests to individual unit tests and
everything in between if you're not into
cyprus another good option for
end-to-end testing as playwright and if
you just want to do unit tests another
framework i've really been wanting to
try out is v-test which is based on vee
the build tool that powers spelt kit my
tech stack also uses a variety of apis
to do things that i can't do on my own
one of which is send transactional email
i currently use sendgrid and will
continue doing so in the future but i
wish firebase or google cloud would come
out with its own email service in
addition a content driven site needs to
have really good full text search to
handle that i'm using algolia algolia
can get pretty expensive on very large
sites but for me it's pretty inexpensive
and very easy to use this is yet another
feature i wish would be implemented into
firebase but i'm not going to hold my
breath and finally i'll be using stripe
and paypal to manage payments because to
be honest i haven't looked at any
alternatives in a long time the end
result is a pretty simple tech stack
with the main components being spelt kit
and firebase the only major problem is
that it doesn't form an obvious acronym
we could go with the fist stack or maybe
fire kit or perhaps [ __ ] it but i don't
know man let me know if you have a
better idea thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one